I only just forgot what are you two
talking about oh nothing just the end of
the world watchmen examines how he as a
society feel about heroes most notably
people who wear masks and fight crime
a little detective Angela right Oh am I
not supposed to know who you are our
watchman honors the graphic novel
without making it necessary to read it
in order to understand this news story
we convinced ourselves that they were
gone but they were just hibernating the
new terrorist organization has emerged
called the seventh Cavalry coordinated
attack forty houses at all pleased and
because of that incident the police
their masks to protect themselves and
their families pretty soon you couldn't
tell the good guys from the bad guys
because they were all hiding their faces
yes ma'am they didn't read me my sorry I
was just kidding I don't care it really
explores the complexity of who you are
when you wear a mask who you are when
you're not wearing a mask masks save
lives
make them cruel
I like watching a TV show where it's
very hard to identify a genre that's
something that I want to replicate for
people who are coming to watchmen for
the first time what makes the show
really cool is that you think you know
and then something happens then you go
oh
don't interrupt we're getting to the
good stuff like all good stories the
truth on the laughs itself slowly oh
[ __ ]
Watchmen just grabs you and takes you on
this and wicked ride
I love twists and storytelling I love
surprises unexpected turns
the vast and it's his conspiracy at play
the show is huge it's the biggest show
I've ever been a part of
and I just forgot hey everybody it's
Charlie's we got a brand new watchman
trailer we have an actual premiere dates
will break it all down there's a whole
bunch of Easter exists for the original
series they also explained during this
how they're handling the original comic
book material because the series isn't
just gonna be retelling the events of
the original series is actually a sequel
to the original Watchmen comic book
we're doing a new Amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best watchman
dr. Manhattan Theory on the video dr.
Manhattan finally coming back I will be
doing episode videos for this just like
I would for a West world or for Game of
Thrones or any of the other big HBO
shows there's a bunch of different time
jumps during this well try to chart it
out as we go along through the timeline
but they give you the basic synopsis so
this picks up in the present day of the
alternate timeline of the events of The
Watchmen series so assume that
everything just continued in that
timeline dr. Manhattan leaves earth
Nixon eventually abolish his term limits
so Robert Redford becomes president
after him and he's been president ever
since you see this newspaper clipping
when Regina King busts into that dudes
trailer to take him down that says
president Redford not seeking another
term there's also Lou Gossett Jr's older
grizzled cop who's helping Regina King I
think he's just supposed to be an older
cop who's retired who gives her some
help in her cases she's trying to take
down this new villain group the seventh
Cavalry he's the one that gives us that
conspiracy teaser there's a vast
conspiracy at play which is obviously a
reference to Ozymandias conspiracy
during the original Watchmen series
although the specific conspiracy that
he's referring to is probably something
different that's spun out of that in
present day on the surface level you
just have this conflict between the
police force in the seventh Cavalry but
then as the creator's tease there's a
lot of bigger stuff happening that Polly
has something to do with dr. Manhattan
coming back to Planet Earth they do a
pretty good job of explaining why
they're all wearing masks the cops are
wearing masks because there's this big
flashback that you see with Regina Kings
character in Black Manta himself he
plays her husband during the series he's
a pretty big actor but I don't know how
big his role in the series is going to
be this is all taking place really early
in the timeline of the show they have
the funeral for the cops that were
killed during the coordinated attack the
reason why there's 51 stars on here I
like this theory is because of
dr. Manhattan did in Vietnam during the
original Watchmen comics series they won
the Vietnam War and supposedly the
theory is crazy as it sounds Vietnam
became an official state kind of weird
that it would become a state before
Puerto Rico and Guam but I guess that's
splitting hairs the weird thing in this
cop lineup too is that explaining why
they're all wearing masks so we protect
our families when we're walking around
in broad daylight when we're not on duty
is you look over in the corner here and
one of the cops is wearing a giant panda
mask I don't know why they're all
wearing yellow and he's suddenly wearing
a panda mask but I think the idea is
based on his character description is
that he's meant to be one of the more
comedic characters but the idea of
comedy within the Watchmen series like
you think of the comedian character is
very different from a traditional
comedic character the one thing they
don't really make clear during this when
they show you all these shots of the 7th
cavalry is what their ethos is what is
it that they're rebelling against why is
it that they formed what is their
operating mission what is it they're
trying to do the only big easter egg
that I can think of aside from them
wearing the Rorschach masks is them
calling their organization the 7th
cavalry is a reference to General Custer
in the Battle of Little Bighorn the 7th
cavalry has been around for a long time
in United States military history but
usually when people refer to the 7th
cavalry and they're talking about
history they're talking about General
Custer in his defeat at the Battle of
Little Bighorn Jean Smart is playing an
older version of Silk Spectre - she also
tells you a little bit about what
happened after the events of the
original series eventually you couldn't
tell the bad from the good with all
those people wearing masks which is part
of the reason why they outlawed
vigilantes in the only way you can
actually be a vigilante now is if you're
a member of the police force or a
federal agency like she is there's also
some Easter eggs for the original
Watchmen series behind Damon Lindelof in
all these shots of him talking about the
series you see that giant squid then
right after it
you see Jeremy Irons eating the giant
squid cake made to look just like the
squid from the end of the original
Watchmen comic book series he's the one
that says masks make men cruel he's
referring to the 7th cavalry characters
that are attacking all these police
officers but also on the flip side of
that battle he's referring to the more
hardcore sadistic people they're
actually working for the police under
the guise of justice like oh I'm a cop
I'm wearing a badge so I can do whatever
want to as long as I'm wearing this mask
that's where you get to the
looking-glass character played by Tim
Blake Nelson I don't think he's supposed
to be a total dirtbag but they do say
that he might be a psycho on the series
you as you see him without his mask on
during some of this footage he's the one
that's pulling people into this special
saucer looking device during what looks
like some big police investigation he
got a lot more footage of Don Johnson's
police chief character he's also the one
inside the a low ship when you see it
flying around through the air looking
like it's getting ready to crash blowing
up this other airplane that's trying to
escape we found out that the name of his
character is Judd Crawford so apparently
he's a brand-new character he's not
someone from the original comic book
series in speaking of a low ship gene
smarts older Silk Spectre character is
using her father the comedians name so I
think that implies that she did not
eventually wind up getting married
tonight
owl but then also you start seeing more
dr. Manhattan Easter eggs you start
seeing clocks everywhere clocks are so
integral to the idea of what Watchmen is
about and to the dr. Manhattan character
himself
there's the Doomsday Clock counting down
to Armageddon they've been using that to
promote the series in combination with
the comedian's smiley face button with
the hands counting down to midnight just
like the Doomsday Clock but dr.
Manhattan's father was a watchmaker he
talks about it during the original
series there's a whole chapter dedicated
to his backstory and him growing up
learning how to serve his clocks how to
take them apart how everything works and
it becomes this big metaphor for how the
world works how everything in existence
works and it's those skills that allow
dr. Manhattan to reconstitute his body
after he gets his powers and he gets
scattered into a billion different
pieces you get a bunch more footage of
the cops trying to bust up this trailer
park community this is probably just
meant to be people associated with the
seventh Cavalry as part of their
investigation Regina King's big thing
during the series is she's leading the
investigation trying to take them down
this scene of the right in the streets
seems like it's a genuine flashback
because it's sepia tone but you also see
the older airplane flying overhead in
the clothes that these people are
wearing is they're running around all
the footage from the last trailer with
the person that seems like a version of
hooded justice seems like an in-universe
version of a nostalgic TV show about the
original adventures of the Minutemen but
it's a show in present-day it'd be like
doing an old timey show set during the
past this
character in the red tracksuit with a
different looking red hood is called Red
Scare he's just a Russian character this
part of the police force he's meant to
be kind of abrasive the woman standing
next to him is named pirate Jenny
another reference to tales of the black
freighter you see the tales of the black
freighter flag-waving past Ozymandias as
he rides by it is really hard to tell
what's going on with his special
technology in Ozymandias basement it
seems incredibly old-timey yet super
advanced so it probably has something to
do with the original machinery that he
was working on during the original
series maybe something that helps him
tap into dr. Manhattan's power but if
you remember during the last trailer
they have a big Easter Egg for the squid
attack at the end of the original
Watchmen comic-book series when you see
all these squid raining down from the
sky in broad daylight is not really
clear what causes that but you see
awesome Andy as pushing down this
detonator setting something up but it
implies that he's going to have a hand
in pushing things along even though he
was secretly behind the big conspiracy
in the last series he might wind up
being more of an asset to them in
present day if you haven't been reading
geoff johns Doomsday Clock comic book
it's also very similar sequel story to
the original Watchmen comic in in
present day Ozymandias is playing one of
the protagonists even though he's trying
to do good he's doing it in a very shady
way lying to a lot of people about his
motives so I'm just expecting more of
that from Jeremy Irons version of this
character it's not really clear at this
carnival disaster is a flashback or if
it's happening at present-day but you
see this giant clown face behind him
nice comedian imagery and then you
finally see dr. Manhattan walking
through the street picking up the blue
mask made to look like his face so
everybody post your theories in the
comments below there's probably gonna be
a couple more trailers before the series
actually gets here
this is also dropping within a couple
weeks of the Mandalorians Star Wars
series on Disney Plus there's gonna be a
bunch of really big series starting
between October and November we also
have The Witcher Netflix coming up we
also have Rick and Morty season 4 I'm
not really expecting to get any more
news about the game of Thrones prequel
or the Lord of the Rings series for a
while I think they're gonna be pretty
quiet about that as long as you have
alerts in Abel for my channel you'll see
all the videos when I post them I'll
name a giveaway winner when I post my
next video right now everybody click
here to watch Christian Bale react to
Robert Pattinson Batman and click here
for my new Star Wars mandalorian trailer
video
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight